die kokain industrie macht jedes jahr 85
milliarden dollar umsatz
über kokain zu schreiben ist wie es
selbst zu nehmen du tust alles um immer
mehr darüber zu erfahren du kannst nicht
aufhören die geschichten zu erzählen
saviano recherchierte fünf jahre lang
inkognito
seerose rom in italien ist dies die
klassifizierung für das mehl mit der
höchsten reinartz stufe der autor
erzählt die geschichte einer branche in
der das geld nicht gezählt sondern
gewogen wird
ein kilo kokain kostet in kolumbien 1500
dollar in italien wird es dann zum
großhandelspreis von 57.000 dollar
weiter verkauft dass ein kilo koks wird
gestreckt gedachten des 3 daraus werden
dann 3000 portionen gemacht in italien
zahlt man für ein gramm 92 dollar das
kokain kostet also in kolumbien 1500
dollar später in italien kostet es
270.000 dollar
wie kokain die welt beherrscht der
neapolitanische kokain jäger spürt
geheime produktionsstätten auf und macht
handelswege publik dazu später aber mehr
denn die pulvrige spur führt auch in
unser leben
bis zu zehn prozent aller schweizerinnen
und schweizer schätzen experten haben
schon mindestens einmal kokain
konsumiert
in zürich sollen jeden tag 21.000 linien
gestopft werden
der krimi autor michael herzig arbeitet
als sucht experte für die stadt zürich
er weiß warum kokain nach alkohol und
cannabis die beliebteste droge unserer
zeit ist
das macht doris das macht aber
egoistisch
empathie für andere und damit passt
einfach so zur wirkungslosigkeit für
mich bei den mafia boss und
treffen mit linda solanki im in club
kaufleuten die junge autorin schreibt in
ihrem erstlingsroman über das leben der
reichen zöglinge an der zürcher
goldküste
kokain gehört hier zum alltag
beschrieben im buch und selbst erlebt
ich bin
eine richtige locherhof wechsel ihnen
jemand hat mich dann geredet und für
mich ist das völlig rom ist sie
dann hat es auch familie linie ziehen
und dann plötzlich sind alle best
friends luft nicht zu erkennen wer bist
du und also
aber kux ist längst nicht mehr nur die
droge der reichen und schönen
sie hat sich sozusagen
demokratisiert die weiße linie sie zieht
sich durch alle gesellschaftsschichten
gesprächstermin in der sucht fachklinik
seel hoffen in burgdorf c ist 21 jahre
alt mit einem schulkollegen name ein
erstes mal kokain es ist ein zweiter
entzug
das euphorische die blue die gute laune
wahrheit wo man mit zwischen mit anderen
frau reiche russen mit der droge
adam kokain und drei tage am stück durch
arbeiten zu können zuerst durch die nase
dann rauchte er den stoff die droge
wirkt dadurch stärker die folge waren
angstzuständen und paranoia und
zurück zum internationalen kokainhandel
zurück zu sehr roh seerose
es liest sich teilweise wie ein drehbuch
für einen überzeichneten action-thriller
allerhand
der markt recht von den usa bis nach
europa es ist ein unglaublich wichtiger
markt wenn die nachfrage steigt hier
täglich das kokain anschauen heißt das
pulver zu sehen durch das kokain
hindurch zu sehen als die welt zu
erkennen
saviano stärke seiner sicht auf die
kriminelle und tödliche kokain welt
zieht den leser in seinen banken saviano
schwächer aber man spürt er ist selber
süchtig
nach den spektakulären geschichten um
die droge unserer zeit